three all right welcome everybody this
is once again Grand Master Alexander
Linderman and here to present to you
lecture on how to play you know on some
romantic games that have been played in
the history of chess last time we've
seen some of stainless games this shows
game today we're gonna take a look at
some more famous immortals and we're
gonna start with the game Edward Lasker
against the Thomas it's kind of a famous
game so maybe some of you have seen it
before but okay so this was a Dutch
defense and here I think blacks should
play d5 for picture before to prevent
the idea that white did in the game but
you know in the game he played Bishop e7
and now how would you continue here with
white to try to play for an edge
while I'm just thinking of the basic
continuing development but there must be
some in strategic tactical
now think about an object that what do
you think you know t5 or Bishop before
would have prevented what idea
either he for moving
um
so any ideas anyone
mm-hmm
well I mean it's not it's not like
something that's like brilliant yet it's
just you know you're gonna try to find a
way to get a slight advantage but not in
a winning or game or anything black
hasn't done anything so bad just you
know focus on the center try to get more
grip on the center somehow yeah a queen
did too you can play again it's a normal
developing move but then I'll just
Castle and I'll be fine even Queens III
I can go t5 so what do you think you
know was the reason why blue t5 maybe
was good because we're trying to then
take on f6 and I'll just go a four
because if we go a 4 then he takes up
tonight so we get rid of the night
normally it's not what we want to do
give up the bishop at night but here
we're concretely going for you for
getting full control over the center and
we're also trying to open up the game
because this King is likely weakened
right so that's why the idea is very
logical yeah exactly yeah yeah
yes so sometimes you know a good idea to
keep in mind is if you see a certain
idea just transpose the move water and
sometimes that might work
so F or F takes Knight takes b6 ok so
now I think the most natural move would
have been to go Bishop d3 just normal
develop move but you know white played
95 now interestingly enough is after 95
that's kind of the reason why white were
in the brilliancy but objectively
speaking black was fine here
so black castled and now he played
Bishop d3 okay so now what should black
to here in this position what do you
think
black what should blog do in this
position
so bishop to be seven at least to
this should be seven which was played in
the game and it's still okay but there's
something in the position that's that's
better once again you have to look at
you know every line you know every
reasonable line at least to potentially
three moves deep because here yeah if
you see the line you know two three
moves deep then you'll be able to figure
it out but of course if you stop you
know after one move it's you're not
gonna find it because positionally again
it looks like not the best move but it
does the job
it's very concrete move
t5i think is possible but I think after
I take how are you gonna capture back ok
you wanna go yeah I mean I guess you
could try to do that but I think I can
go Quidditch 5 or queen chief queen
chief or maybe better and then Queen h4
I think it would be a little bit
dangerous just too many ideas too many
ideas for whites
yeah but you take what the Queen that
after I Castle you know you're just
stuck with a very bad structure Knight
only five is completely dominating the
bishop is bad the knight is on an
outpost so just positionally it's not
good I mean I unless you would have
something very concrete it wouldn't work
so d5 is one of these moves which it's
not very challenging and it you know
weakens a lot of squares c5 I think it
might be too slow because I think I can
still try my queen h5 idea d6
probably I can yeah I mean all these
moves are fine but in this position um
black has moved that actually believe it
or not gives him an advantage it's very
unusual but we have to always consider
it cap checks then captures and threats
so we have to look at this move even
though it looks like not a very pretty
move you know giving letting the pawn
get here Queen h5 removing a defender
but it still concrete we got a look at
moves like that and now we got a look at
again you know checks captures threats
how can we attack this pawn
yes we can we can go knight c6 attack
the spawn which is now a little bit
loose and we can develop and attack at
the same time and believe it or not
blackish is doing very well now there's
only one wait logical way he can defend
the bonus by queen h5 but now after
simply rook a 5 which is swing a pawn so
in fact black was just much better now
this is very easy to overlook because
you think okay this is just not a move
that you look at because it's just so
unusual it's like an invisible move
gopikas okay it's
I think so I think I mean this was like
what I think one of these exhibition
games so it was but as often times HAP
times happens in their absolute
brilliance ease they start actually not
perfect but they're created by opponents
even less perfection in some ways so
actually you know but this is still good
to note of notice these kind of moments
because you know during the game you can
get an opportunity like that during the
game and it's very important to take
advantage of such opportunities to be
able to win a pawn like that but instead
black to continued normally with
development Queen h5 and now you know he
made a mistake
he played Queen East 7 and that was a
mistake so who can tell us what should
white play in this position so hopefully
somebody who hasn't seen the game before
so has anyone already seen the game
before you have right ok
okay so I'll give you guys like a few
minutes see if you can't could find the
idea
yes night six I take with the porn
yeah so that's what that was that's why
he played Queenie 7 what Queenie 7 stops
one idea but it doesn't stop
another very brilliant idea
95 very interesting but if I go g6
ya could but um I think I have a few
choices here I can take on g5 let's say
no no I was just letting you kind of
figure it out but
yes so it's actually yeah 96 okay I
still play jeez oh no sorry mouseland
I mean even in the slime the problem is
your night will get trapped there
somehow it's just kind of yeah so but in
any way there might be something better
than just being like a p'pon and an end
game or something so yeah that's why in
every position we got to always look at
all of our checks captures and threats
so let's start looking at our checks
what are all of our possible checks in
the position Queen Dex h7 Knight 6 of 6
and Queen f7 well Queen of 7 is of
course stupid he can take with the rope
take with the queen queen of 7 doesn't
make sense but what about nitrix of 6 we
looked at a little bit GF it's possible
move but it doesn't seem to win the game
right away at least
what about Queen takes h7 ok he's forced
to take and now we can do a double check
and already this is very interesting
because oh he cannot go there because of
96 so then he has to go there it's
almost made and you look mm-hmm I mean
and now this is where we can really look
deeper because it looks like wow the
king is very very close to getting made
it and then that's where we can realize
that ok this maybe is worth analyzing
and in fact white wins in a brilliant
way in this position starting with this
check King goes up h4 King goes up g3
all with checks
King goes up should be 2 king goes up
and King the tour you can also Castle
what made all forced with checks so this
is definitely aligned that could be
calculated but in order to calculate
that you have to not just reject Queen
takes h7 and general principles but at
least realize that such a move works and
once we realize that this could be
interesting then the rest is a matter of
execution kind of just trying to work it
out and if you have a very very good
intuition that it might work then you go
for it it's like remember when I was
showing that watch actually you weren't
there for the tactics lecture but it's
different so this was how the game
played out this was a beautiful game
Edward Lasker not even the world
champion last row but
Oscar against thumps alright now I'm
gonna show you a game from that Alekhine
won against an unknown player and what
makes this more impressive is that it
was actually a blindfold game so
Alekhine was white and it was against n
n blindfold game none known and here of
course the most natural move is to take
on Edie but black played Knight 65 which
you know can't be too good because it
keeps the bishop locked in and white
played very creatively played Knight e4
it was also possible to go Knight of 3
or anything but okay 94 is interesting
and now white is a little bit better
because he has more grip in the center
f5
certain a very risky move weakening the
square already h6 would be losing moot
because of Queen h5 so this should be 7
Knight back to f3 he didn't want to go
like this because h6 probably when a
knight has to go here so he played there
she's 695 so he knew that he can then
reposition the Knights in a convenient
way that's why maybe black should have
played here first or knight c6 but he
played c6 and now both sides complete
development in normal way
alright and here's a critical moment of
the game a white to play what should why
to
ah actually does 96's does win a pawn
it's not a bad move but you know as we
know in order for the game to be
brilliant we probably are looking for
something maybe even more but certain
nights you six you know is is also
probably giving a very big advantage but
let's try to find a you know a romantic
move more brilliant way to play
it's just the beautiful concept that's
why I wanted to
Knight of 7 King takes of sir
alright let's continue 95 probably also
works and then you know you meet King g6
with Queen takes c6 I'm pretty sure this
also as a mate but III like what why did
even more because it's even more
beautiful he went Queen taxi six Jack
because the thing is after this is has
made waiting one and if King f8 you go
Knight g5 and there is no way to stop
the maid here I mean you can prolong it
for a couple of moves but you know it's
still gonna be made so you have to go
King g6
and then white play the maiden - I mean
look in this position like you can win
and pretty much anyway but it shows g4
most elegant threatening mates here and
threatening wait here no defense but of
course this is not necessary you can
also do this to a forced mate but again
it's like one of these beautiful
combinations and kind of elegant so I
figure I'll I'll show you this one as
well alright now we're gonna see another
one and this one is between rot Valley
and Rubinstein and Rubinstein was black
yes so we're finally looking at a game
from the black side I know we've mostly
looked at games from the white side now
and we're gonna look at a game from a
black site and I know a lot of
Rubinstein fans ok so this game actually
started off very slowly so as you could
as you'll see from the next few games
you can even sometimes have brilliant
sees that start off kind of very slowly
it's kind of yes it's just a symmetrical
structure which you know has been seen a
lot of times very often why does the one
who plays like waiting move a three just
kind of seeing what blacks what
structure block wants to play and a
three is kind of a useful movement for
example in these positions a three is
useful because it stops night before
ninety five and you're also preparing
some Queens III Bishop before Bishop e3
Bishop c2 and there's no more night
before and also it's useful in case of
you know you get the Bishop escape
square but okay in this game he took
first and then played a3 which is okay
black played a6
before Bishop d6 there should be two
castles and here I think white started
playing but strangely that think he
removed like rook c1 is okay re move
like CD but he played he played them of
Queen d2 which I think it's not very
good c5 might be playable as well I mean
I'll go here and then you play like
Bishop e2 it might be playable I'm not
sure but this of course you know you're
giving up the center so it's a little
bit more double-edged so I like the move
of keeping the tension rooks you wanna
seeing what black does Queen d2 is
played queenie 73
and now it seems like yeah after b5 this
should be seven black is getting the
more comfortable side of equality and
then as you saw Queen d2 then he later
ended up losing a temple to go Queen e2
so it's pretty clear that Queen d2 was
not great so now black is playing 95
does two things remove the defender and
also opening up the nice diagonal for
this Bishop Knight 65 Bishop takes e5 f
for Bishop c7 of course he doesn't
really want to trade
so ship c7 because otherwise he gets two
bishop sent the bishop is gonna be very
nice in this long diagonal so he went
here before rook c8 d five here a ninety
four so the idea being after this we go
Rotex d3 and we'd get two bishops and
hope pressure on the d file threatening
rooks III and just a lot of good things
happening for black so I played the ship
e4
all right how do we continue the attack
in this position
clean
yea-ah night's xh2 by the way was also a
viable option but Queen h4 is a good
move as long as you see the follow up so
g3 and this is the critical moment of
the game how does block display you know
the crushing attack
seems like white has everything under
control but Rubenstein when you played
finish four he is so deeper so any ideas
I'll give you a few minutes here
mm-hmm rook takes c3 is the correct
first move
yes I removal the guard so one line is
easy to calculate now if you'd like if
you go here you just take on g3 and it's
crushing and if you take here you take
on e4 and you're winning on edge to the
big moment is of course what happens if
you take the Queen and you know this
move has to be and also seen like before
you even play Queen h4 otherwise it
might seem okay you gave up the Queen
but where is the attack but this next
move is absolute key move to the whole
attack
absolutely that is correct move because
now you know no matter what Y does he's
just losing first of all if you take the
night taking here and here you're gonna
end up upper rook so taking the night
losses taking the rook was played in the
game if you take this rook
I was also threatening this by the way
so roughly two also comes with a very
big threat so white isn't huge trouble
if you take this rook I also take here
are taking a looking a druggy to in
which position in this position but here
I can take here maybe
take the night but now I don't have to
take your queen anymore I can take on b7
right so that's why you know you have to
take the night first because that forces
the queen you know trading the Queens
because you're now threatening this and
only after this you corrupt it sooo so
the move orders of course very important
so why took here here Queen here all
right
black to play what to do yeah I think
Roxy too would also work actually but he
played rock h3 threatening mate and this
would this was the end of the game
because if you take on e4 take on h2 and
of Queenie for your gauge to and
otherwise it's just winning no wait to
do anything
- see - it takes a little while
oh yeah probably I mean you could play
like rook F no it's no it's also winning
yeah look G one out of two
yeah I mean it's a rook sheets or catch
three are both winning it doesn't matter
so much
alright so that was a Rubenstein
technodrome these are just a couple of
inaccuracies and suddenly white got this
black got this beautiful attack conk
okay here's another game Levitsky
against Marshall another black game now
the opening wasn't you know perfect from
black which often happens in his lines
Marshall play this move c5 it's only
recommended if you go to rush French but
against Knight c3
I think c5 isn't very good because you
could just take taken to go Knight f3 or
even this should be five check-ins I
think here white is better he has a lot
of pressure on d5 and it's like a good
version of the iqp for white so but in
the game he played Knight f3 knight c6 c
de d and play it's kind of passively
with this should be two black played
Knight of 6 castles should be seven here
he doesn't take right away because t5
hangs them so he played Bishop e6 and
now 94 again white should probably
defend this pawn but he played 94 an
already black is comfortable so it was
one of these openings which a white kind
of played passively didn't play most
principled away and already black got a
comfortable game but look how black
takes advantage of his opportunities all
his pieces gain in the game now
potentially with threatening g4 and 94
stuff okay Quincey to keep looking at
there to square and Ashley Bishop takes
c3
yeah and now we're getting closer to the
what we call it's called the gold coin
game actually because I heard that after
the move that Marshall played in this
game
everybody threw gold coins 94 Queen h5
Rock f-85 here 25 rook takes h3 rook c5
and what does black play here yeah Queen
g3 although the funny thing is even if
you go kun a3 or queen before it's still
winning but there would no not be gold
coins but in the game ko in g3 was
played and you know there's no matter
how you you know you basically put the
Queen and so three attackers it's just
pretty pretty move right because of FG
goal 92 and this is made right away and
even after Queen takes you still go
hereand technically it doesn't you know
winner right away but it's just the
fancy way to trade off into a winning
endgame but you know it's still you know
perfectly good alright one more kind of
a early century game and then we'll
gonna look at like more modern examples
this is a game which Murphy played with
white against also an unknown player and
here we have the four scotch gam gambit
against the two Knights defense but
white played this interesting hybrid
between scotch gambit and fried liver
now in general this is not supposed to
be all that good for white
but black has to play precisely here for
example if black plays the move 95 black
is totally fine for example here you can
go h6 and if takes you can go takes
takes d5 or even Queen e7 and there
would not be any brilliance this black
would just be comfortable but I get like
I said in order for there to be
brilliancy sometimes you have to play a
little unsound in the beginning an
opponent to react even more and soundly
and then that would be an opportunity
for some brilliance ease so in the game
black played d5 the move is still okay
but after eg black has to play here
precisely the best move is probably
queen e7 you know and then you're trying
to play 95 you know looking at these
ideas black is actually slightly better
here with perfect play but then he took
with a knight and the thing about this
line is in case some of you play fried
liver there's this line of d5 eg and
then there's of course the main line is
Knight a5 there's some other lines but
if you go Knight 65 Knight 6 of 7 is of
course very promising but there's also
d4 it's also very interesting move with
the idea that after eg then you can do a
fried liver even under better
circumstances of course black doesn't
have to take but then either away White
has an advantage here so this was kind
of like he got the best version of the
fried liver as a result after Knight 65
and white castles first and the thing is
black cannot really stop any kind of
light except 7 ideas and now white will
be perfectly ready for it you will be
Castle dent it's winning
so Bishop e7 is played
and Knight c3 very unusual move but one
of the ideas is just to speed up the
development interesting life you're
giving up a night just to speed up the
development so let's see the whole point
of this so easy rook you 195 mish before
so of course you have to go 95 otherwise
I'm just taking and mating you so you
have to go 95 Bishop before Bishop d6
okay now Queen takes d5 probably also
wins but more fears always was a
beautiful player I couldn't really you
know talk about romantic games and not
once show more fee game so there it is
Bishop takes e5 so I tried to show at
least the one game that's not the most
famous one
not everybody's has seen Bishop takes d5
65 rook takes and that's why back then
he played Knight c3 remember Knight c3
so that in this position you can go
rookie one with a temple and now if you
go back 25 is made so block went here
Bishop takes d5 and yeah it's a quiet
move but we have three pieces attacking
the King on g4 it's pretty clear that
it's not going to be surviving and in
many different ways
so black tried this move Queen c3 before
if King here then I think you go Queen
check and do this check and mate that's
just one of the lines probably more than
one way to mate so took here and if King
g6 you can even drop back here and it's
mate so you go here and here black
resigned because almost 90 line it's
made for example King here here they're
here they're here probably why it's
mating in more than one ways three
pieces attacking the open King the rule
is usually it will be made
okay so now I would like to show you
guys a more complicated game
Kasparov against Apollo and that's also
a relatively famous one but I would say
is it was very romantic so that's well
I'll show you
so Kasparov was white against the polyp
that was in 1999 it was a Perce defense
these are all pretty natural moves um
well if he castles
then I'm gonna go h4 h5 and to go for a
very big attack so it's it's okay
because actually black has a flexibility
of castling long here so the idea is
fine here in this position why I think
white played a very nice move so in the
long run white wants to cast alone at
some point but if he does it here then
there's some Queen f5 before ideas so
white played a very interesting
prophylaxis move a3 first kind of
keeping an eye on blacks ideas before c5
and so on and then you know going from
there so a3 prophylaxis first and then
he's gonna continue with his attack a
5v5
room to castles 27 can be won a
six-night c1 so repositioning the knight
to potentially more prospect squares
castles long 93 why does a little bit
better but black is definitely very much
in the game so he played a 64 our Luke
takes T 4 C 5 T 1
I'd be six so that's preparing t5g three
can be eight and here a white made an
inaccuracy but then again as often
happens in order to player brilliancy
sometimes you have to play a little bit
inaccurate
otherwise it's won't do brilliance it
would just be a nice technical game like
a Carlsen type game where you just
squeeze squeeze and win but in order to
produce a romantic game sometimes you
have to actually play with inaccurately
maybe not on purpose but it's like
usually almost every brilliancy at some
point has some inaccuracies from the
winning side one way or another for
whatever it may be it's a coincidence
but you know again that's what makes
just beautiful that it's like more more
like an art rather than a science
sometimes yeah sometimes even if you
make a mistake it actually can you know
that's you know gives you all hope that
even if you make a mistake and actually
can make your game you know more
beautiful later so white played 95 the
move objective lives a mistake because
it's decentralizing and kind of makes
the night off side for now night and III
impacts the game a lot in this way
because it prevents d5 so best move
would be something like Queen a4 and
then g4 preparing some Knight c5 let's
say King a7 and now you can go to chief
or Knight 65 for example you can't play
d5 because of knight 65 so a move like
that would have been better or maybe
Bishop h3t 5et and rook e1 so basically
not letting black get t5 and so easily
would have been a better idea like
playing more flexible keep keeping the
night on b3 for now because not a5 can
at some point come anyway but once you
go Knight a5 you lose your flexibility
block goes there and now g5 will be much
easier for black to get in and uh
objectively speaking block is fine here
maybe even better so Bishop h3 happened
now but now g5 came and now there was
you know no night putting at putting
pressure on the center so black was
comfortably able to get d5 maybe what
Kasparov saw is Queen a 14 8 7
rookie one and thinking okay he still
has a very nice initiative okay first of
all here maybe D takes e4 was also
playable but he played D 495 Knight 65
it takes d5 Queen d6 okay so first
critical moment in the game what do you
think whites should do here I mean even
if it's not objectively the best move I
think from practical standpoint of view
it was definitely a good move and I'll
explain why but first try to find it
to
before they mean here or e5 yeah um I
think Bishop takes d5 I just I just play
rook e8 many ways I can yeah basically
what's happened in this position is that
tides have kind of changed and if you
play in a normal way like this this
rookie seven
I'll go king b6 and I'll take on g5 I'll
be better at this point if you're
playing in a normal way so that's why
good or bad you have to try to go for
complications at this point you have to
try to go for something interesting
because if you're gonna go for something
kind of dull yours is gonna be worse you
know if you kind of play in a normal way
right so white played route x d4 so now
of course if Queen texif or you take
with the rook so black has to do
something about it now objectively
speaking the best move from practical
standpoint of view and maybe even
objectively was king b6 and then okay
white wouldn't have nothing better than
that's you know we'll get go through the
game you know that was the game yes so I
think bish takes d5 was okay after which
you know we have complicated lines after
up texts e5 which leads to very big mess
and also there is king b6 which
objectively speaking black is actually
doing quite well here I mean you can try
something like Knight b3 but the thing
is you can even just take on t5 you
don't have to take the rook which leads
to some attacking possibilities so King
b6 was the best but I guess he thought
okay CD is also fine but now white
followed up with the brilliant scans
nation which maybe
topalov overlooked which doesn't quite
win the game completely but it certainly
puts black and
edge
mm-hmm yes so now if ego queen 7 you
lose after quint XD for king b8 Queen b6
this should be 7 knight c6 King 8 Queen
esalaam 8 so that line is pretty easy
King b8 is also not so good because of
Queen txt for threatening this mate
which forces 97 bish 67 and then problem
is the stroke hangs also in a lot of
lines so you have to try this and see
forint white is doing very well here as
well and the reason we place the 4 is
otherwise this was a threat so it's I
mean unusual line but this is good for
white so black played correctly King b6
principled Queen takes d4 and now black
played King takes a 5 there was also
line Queen takes e5 2 index of 6 Queen
d6
but then Bishop e6 was very powerful
which led to still a very complex game
probably good for white but in the game
King takes a 5 was played before
kink here okay so here we have a
critical moment so white is down a root
and the night but of course the king is
on a4 so we're looking for ways to
attack it and in this position
technically speaking
Kasparov made a mistake but of course
you know to figure out why the best move
was the best move is very hard so I'll
give you guys a chance what do you think
was best move for white here
all black can take the deep wound anyway
I mean that's can't really defend
against that really hmm
ruh k7r okay seven was actually the best
move in the position okay seven first
because actually black is in white in a
way is not in a rush you'll still need
to play this move eventually and here's
the point so black has two main defenses
965 and this should be seven because if
you go Bishop takes d5 oh but then let's
see
just very quickly
then you go Quincy three and then there
is no defense from King beats King b2
and Queen b3 sorry
okay so Bishop takes d5 then you go
Queen b3 Queen c3 and then there's no
defense from King b3 King b2 and Queen
b3 so 965 doe could be could have been
the reason why he did not do that
because now there is no more Queen c3
and black is actually threatening night
six before and getting rid of the you
know the poor information that leads to
the attack but now white plays rook
takes a six double exclam queen takes a
six Queen B - now you need it to play
rook takes a six because if you don't do
that if you play Queen B - right away
then I think I'm I can take this and
then I can go Queen check and after this
I can go there and suddenly it's black
who wins even this doesn't work because
the porn is capturable and black is just
completely winning so sorry
so Ciroc takes a six was best move and
now couldn't be 296 before now was Queen
before mate so Queen b3 is threatened so
not only move as Knight c3 Queen takes
Bishop g5 King bee - Queen e6
takes takes Queen b3 mates porn mates
you know
so that's beautiful but maybe he missed
that concept there is also Bishop e7
which was one of the defense's that
black used in the game now you can take
with the rook and now there is two moves
of one move as Queen takes d5 then you
go rogue b6 threatening mate
rook a8 and Queen Dex of sick sent here
White has a decisive attack and there's
also beautiful line after a five here
here and now Queen III preparing you
know this and this so and amazingly
white also wins rook takes a six king
bee to a be a be threatening Queen eight
three King takes check and check again
all these lines it's like for human to
calculate it's almost impossible
precisely
it's like you have to play an ear
intuition and up night 65 White has
another absolutely beautiful move Bishop
g7 like I mean good luck finding that in
a real game rook takes the seven queen
bee to Knight c3 and the nose against
some beautiful lines which and would
like a mate threat again in that's why
when we look at games and shows bomb and
let's say in this position the engine
would say rock a 7 is plus 9
Queen C 3 is equal well you know for us
following the game on just bummed as
fans it's very easy to say criticized oh
what a pot sir you know this GM didn't
find you know this beautiful concept but
once you with this it's like you're okay
7 is so obvious you know you attack the
mate you know but of course you know
when you dig deeper and when people show
the complicate variations then it
becomes clear that it's not just like a
1 or 2 move idea that you didn't see
that there's some huge subtlety 5 moves
down the line that it's sometimes unfair
to criticize players based on what we
see in the chess engines when we follow
the top players games so on the game
Queen c3 was played totally good-looking
human move but black had a defense
against this Queen takes d5 so first
point is of course not King bitsu
because the Queen d4 and so that's where
rock a7 was important Bishop e7
so now again you you have to be careful
so roofed xb7 was played and in this
position black played 24 still so so in
a game rook takes be sevens plate and
now black has a few defenses so rock h h
e8 then you can go to b6 r ok 8 and the
ship f1 with the idea of going king
bitsu and if you go king bit so right
away it's like there's query 5 that's
why you don't put the king right away
there but the thing is it's one of these
where black cannot do anything it's very
mysterious but it's completely winning
for example rook e1 here you probably
could just take that it's like one of
these semi waiting moves where your
potential in some lines prepared which
takes b5 and black cannot really do
anything
it's not a threat right now but it's an
idea in some cases maybe sometimes it
might be an idea but really we're
looking at all these other ideas and
probably Bishop of one is some deep
prophylaxis against something but in any
event
Quincy for was played in the game to
kind of six and now it's blacks turn to
miss very nice defense
rugby one was best move then if you go
Quincy four then you actually lose
because there's no defense from this
stuff but you can go Roque eight Queen
b6 and now you can go queen g4 takes
takes rook f7 a5 just in time to create
some counter play and I mean yeah you
can go King b6 also and this kind of
endgame maybe is still some drone
chances although probably it's being for
white in the game instead Rock a eight
was I mean sorry in the game yeah rook
in the game King takes a three was
played Queen takes a six King takes
before c3 well what else you know you
have to continue the attack otherwise
Ruby one Queen c3 was coming so C 3 and
now Kings to five easily losses because
of this King
Quinn takes the pawn you just yeah and
if King be three then you go Quinn check
check and you can probably go Bishop of
one also but rookie seven is more
clinical it threatens May 10th so black
played King takes and now Queen I want
Shaq King has to keep going on a journey
if King if King here then Queen be to
check it's now Queen B three losses to
this King a four losses to locate seven
kings C five losses to this so King a
five is the only move check here on
rubies so King D 2 is forced Queen B -
and King T 1 all right
how should the white continue the attack
King III I think I go rookie 7 Queen G 2
so kingi one was played so I think I
briefly showed the answer but to those
of you who haven't seen it how should
white continue the attack because it
looks like white is running out of steam
here
very good
yeah because otherwise I'm threatening
here so you need to somehow deflect the
Queen now if Queen takes here
how does white win in this position
Queen c2 very good then Ruby seven so
black had to go rook t2 only move okay
and now try to find the final blow
rook rook we're very good yeah and this
is basically over because now there is
just no way to defend the position we're
either losing the Queen or we losing or
getting made it so black took on g7 why
to can see four takes takes and yeah now
I mean there's still practical chances
even here with this pawn but white of
course was up to par here his technique
he brings the Queen back to try to guard
the point is you can't let that one get
to see to as long as you control the c2
square you're in good shape
so that's why this will actually be a
little bit inaccurate I think because
after this King goes to d2 and then
eventually the row can come around and
start checking and the pawn can get here
so it's very important to go there to
threaten Queen a4 and kind of get the
Queen to c2 before the black king can
really do anything before black can
coordinate himself so c3
so see three happened Queen check ah
if King did sue then I probably Quincy
too
so King he won and now white just played
a four it's you know just good to not
give up the porn basically so white
player for preparing King c2 black well
because if you Queen coming back then
I'm just taking this porn so you don't
really want to give up the porn unless
you have to right so that's why a four
because otherwise if you're gonna give
up a porn like this there's more chance
of a fortress at some point even if you
win the c3 pawn there might be some
fortresses at some point but if you keep
the pawn there it's very unlikely
there's gonna be a fortress with Queen
against rook so a five kings c1 the most
important thing is to maintain the porn
basically not allowed any counter
planned then the Queen is actually
better off actually just trying to win
these pawns sort of the two trying to go
after this pawn and I think this is yeah
now Queen e7 and I think black resigned
here because very nice geometrical move
because after this you go here and
otherwise if you start winning these
pawns than the Queen just takes it from
there and at this point it's clear once
the Kings on c1 then black has no way to
dislodge it because black does not have
a knight a bishop or even another pawn
in the B file so the King on c1 is
totally safe blockading the porn so
usually in these kind of end games in an
ideal world you want the King being the
bloke hater of the porn and the queen
being the aggressor going after the
points otherwise you're not going to be
able to win an endgame like that usually
in these kind of end games the heavy
pieces are the ones that are supposed to
be the aggressive pieces the grassers
and attacking opponents weaknesses and
the king is supposed to be the defender
you know if you can get that kind of a
setup usually you're in good
Yesi - first of all there's not even a
threat but second of all you can even
win the Rokia but even if even if there
is there is no threat because softer
check you can always go here only if the
king call comes here then you have to be
careful then this becomes a threat but
of course by then I can do 26 check or
Queen a5 or something like that
yeah what would with this complex game I
think you know I guess it's time to
finish for today's so let's see if
anyone has any questions for me today
it's a good question but I I wouldn't
know I would read about it and some
articles probably mentioned somewhere
but
[Music]
you